so Titan Hulk fights an army of 500
World breaker Hawks in this video and
it's amazing check this out so what this
does is this initially picks up with
Bruce Manor in control of Starship Hulk
now people who have no idea what's going
on in The Incredible Hulk Mythos right
now are probably like what
explain this to me man so here's what's
happening right now in years past you
had the Incredible Hulk who turned into
Bruce Banner and Bruce Banner who turned
into the Incredible Hulk the angrier The
Incredible Hulk got the stronger he
became what's been going on recently and
we didn't know how Bruce Banner did it
but we are going to find out in this
video what Bruce Banner managed to do
was basically take control of the
Incredible Hulk's body and then have the
Incredible Hulk Persona operate as a
kind of engine for his own body so
literally what Bruce Banner does is he
just bombards the Incredible Hulk
personality with an endless onslaught of
increasingly powerful characters it
starts off with somebody like Wolverine
and goes all the way up to people like
Thanos they're all just psychic
projections but the Hulk personality
doesn't know that and so it just
continues to fight over and over and
over and over again and because the
Incredible Hulk gets stronger the
angrier he gets by increasing the
difficulty of the villains that the Hulk
personality has to fight that's how
Banner controls how strong The
Incredible Hulk gets to be or at least
the body gets to be it's pretty cool but
of course with him in control of
Starship Hulk he basically crash lands
on a world that he's not familiar with
because at this point in time the
Incredible Hulk or really Banner is
traversing the Multiverse he's literally
exploring the whole Multiverse what
makes sense of all that as we go through
this video but in arriving on this world
he doesn't recognize anything here the
only thing he sees that even just seems
remotely recognizable is just this giant
Citadel that's been built and seemingly
it's been built in his honor because
there's just a giant statue of The
Incredible Hulk now of course he's
almost immediately set upon by just
these crazy monstrous looking Hulk type
things that are called the gray but then
he's almost immediately rescued by a
chick named monolith now we'll learn
more about her because she's incredibly
important here but what she does is she
explains what's going on in this
alternate reality that Bruce Banners in
and what she says is that at some point
along the line Aegis whole bunch of
Hulks suddenly arrived on this world
they literally fell through a portal and
arrived on this world and that they did
what hawks do they just started smashing
things they were smashing the world to
such a degree that they terraformed it
they terraformed a planet through
smashing it and that's going to be one
of the craziest things because every
single one of these hulks are all World
breaker level but of course as they're
smashing and basically terraforming this
world as time progresses the exceedingly
violent nature of these original hulks
begins to go away and what they end up
doing is forming a more organized and
structured Society now the other part of
this seems to be that with the loss of
their violent nature their gamma
radiation almost seems to kind of
dissipate in the sense that they do have
enough gamma to basically maintain their
forms some level of their strength but
by and large they're just kind of really
strong guys and that's it but then like
out of nowhere the sun seemingly
explodes and there's just like this
giant Vestige of the original Hulk right
the main Hulk and he just starts
blasting them like covering them all
with gamma radiation now that's how
monolith describes it what's actually
really going on here is it looks like
the arrival of this original Hulk kind
of reawakens all the gamma radiation
inside their bodies and turns them back
into their exceedingly strong cells
basically sends them back into their
world breaker forms and so looking at
the original Hulk or the main Hulk as
kind of the person that returned them to
Glory they built the whole statue and
everything and so while monolith doesn't
really know the significance of where
all the original hooks came from by
passing through a portal or seeing a
Vestige of the main Hulk and the sky we
do know all that stuff and this was all
based on the previous story arc which
you'll find a link to in the comments
section make sure you guys check for a
pinned comment that'll take you to that
video but the way the previous storyline
played out is that when Bruce Banner
first entered into the Multiverse he
encountered an alternate reality version
of him self and that alternate Bruce
under the direction of that universe's
version of Thunderbolt Ross was
basically trying to create an army of
Hulk those who were considered to be
failures or cast offs were literally
just sent to a wormhole and no one knew
where they went to they were just out of
sight out of mind and that was basically
it now everything popped off and we saw
the Titan Hulk for the first time which
we'll talk about in this video and so on
and so forth but that's where they
originally came from what is important
here is that monolith brings Hulk
basically to all the other hulks in this
city and kind of presents him as sort of
the original right like the one they all
Champion as the person that gave them
all their gamma radiation right like the
Hulk above all hulks if you want to call
them that right the prime Hulk and so
they see him very much as kind of a
champion of the people more so than that
what they also do is they bring him into
something called the god ball games now
this is just an indication of how strong
these different hulks are right this
planet has three rings of rocks
surrounded in the same way that Saturn
has rings right so what these hulks do
is they jump to a neighboring world
world and they smash the world right
they literally just beat it and they
hammer it all the way down to the point
that it's as close as far as the atomic
structure of everything that it can
possibly get right there's no way to
compact this core any further and when
they have that they call it a god ball
they bring the god ball back to Hulk
Planet which is what this place is
called then they use it as a game they
throw it at the rocks and whoever
destroys the most rocks wins the idea of
breaking a world is now just a game of
sport breaking worlds is just what they
do for fun and it's just nuts right it's
just a whole different level of strength
and so of course basically the
Incredible Hulk participates in the
whole thing he's just like sure why not
grab the giant core of a planet that's
been condensed down to virtually nothing
and start throwing it into things for
sport and for fun why not be a part of
this now seemingly the god ball games
are just interrupted out of nowhere by a
group that's referred to as the
alternative Universe timeline Hazard
operations response and intervention
team which if you you've put those
acronyms together correctly spells
Authority now is it the authority from
DC Comics No but it's absolutely a
Pastiche on the team it's basically just
Donnie Cates and Marvel Comics making
fun of the authority they're over the
top they present themselves with this
Grand level of authority that none of
them have and of course they're
basically going after the Hulk because
the whole kid basically destroyed the
previous version of authority as he was
flying through the Multiverse now of
course at this point monolith chimes in
and says well actually what was
happening is the Hulk was sleeping
didn't really know what he was doing
your guys just got in his way and with
the Hulk being as strong as he is he
plowed through your entire team so
that's really the only reason why this
happened now of course the other thing
that ended up happening is that the Hulk
himself along with a guy named pave
who's another one of the hulks here is
actually just transported to a different
world which they proceed to smash and
create another God ball out of but the
authority is being here is really more
of just kind of a goofy moment it's just
a silly moment I just thought it'd be a
funny thing to reference otherwise we
would have normally just skipped over it
but of course with like the Hulk himself
returning alongside pave as well as
having the god ball they continue on
with the grand games themselves
completely and blissfully unaware of the
fact that the Hulk personality inside
the Incredible Hulk body is starting to
become disillusioned and the Titan Hulk
is starting to manifest again now here
is where things get a little murky when
it comes to the nature of the Titan Hulk
when the Titan Hulk first manifested in
Marvel Comics it manifested as a
personality Inside the Mind Of The
Incredible Hulk itself meaning you had
Bruce Banner's personality you had the
Hulk's personality then you had another
that showed up in the form of Betty Ross
now we knew right off the bat it was not
Betty Ross and even within the story
Bruce Banner knew it wasn't Betty Ross
but we didn't really know what it was
what ends up happening is that over the
course of this story that personality
starts to appear as Brian Banner the
abusive father of Bruce Banner but do
not be fooled by the appearance that the
Titan Hulk takes that when it does
appear to the whole personality it shows
up as almost kind of like a shadow King
type entity right very malevolent it's
difficult to make out its exact form
it's very a dark very scary very murky
that kind of a thing spouting stuff like
your soul belongs to me your mind
belongs to me it's only a matter of time
before I take over yada yada all the
kind of stuff you expect to see and even
when the whole personality goes to
attack the Titan Hulk Persona the Titan
hold Persona just shuts it down right I
mean just easily overtakes that version
of the Hulk like that I mean it's not
even a contest and in fact we'll see
just how powerful this guy is because
it's next level but one of the things to
know is that with the Titan Hulk
personality basically amping up and
beginning to seize control we've only
ever seen glimpses of how powerful the
Titan Hulk is and this video we'll find
out just what this dude is capable of
now the other part of this is that once
the Titan hole Persona does take hold
Stephen Strange actually picks up on it
now here's the thing about this yes
within Marvel Comics those of you guys
who are reading Stephen Strange is
technically dead this story takes place
after the death and return of Stephen
Strange why because it's comic books and
nothing stays changed forever and so
with Titan Hulk taking control of
everything think Doctor Strange actually
ends up getting involved but the reason
he gets involved is not for the reason
that you think and so what this does is
this leads to the Titan Hulk actually
initiating a series of enemies against
the Hulk personality under the belief
that in doing so the whole personality
will just face off against this endless
horde of enemies grow more and more
powerful and then when that time comes
basically amp himself up and allow the
Titan Hulk to take over right allow the
Titan Hulk to seize control and then
manifest in a physical form the problem
with this is that Bruce Banner and the
whole personality are actually
meditating together which is something
that they've done over the course of
Donnie Kate's run so far they literally
sit down meditate and they don't allow
anything to bother them and so for the
most part all these threats that
literally keep being thrown against the
Hulk none of them seem to have any
bearing whatsoever even when you have
like a manifestation of the Phoenix
Thanos Galactus none of it seems to
really impact the Hulk on a meaningful
level but at the end of the day the
Titan Hulk pushes things to the absolute
limit and literally amps off the
Incredible Hulk to the max level the
highest level he possibly can and just
explodes and that's the nature of the
Titan Hulk the Titan Hulk is the answer
to the question when Bruce spanner gets
pushed to his limits he becomes the
Incredible Hulk what happens when the
Hulk hulks out you get the Titan Hulk
it's a pretty awesome concept because
when that happens the Titan Hulk is now
in full control now jumping to Doctor
Strange this is the reason why he's
getting involved in the first place so
while we didn't initially know how it
was that Banner was able to take over
the mind of the Hulk and then Force the
whole personality to basically become
the engine system where we didn't know
how he was able to turn the Incredible
Hulk body into basically a vessel that
could Traverse the Multiverse without
being destroyed by the pressures of just
space time and all that kind of stuff we
end up finding out that Bruce Banner had
previously met with Doctor Strange and
Doctor Strange had actually showed him
how to do that right he had shown him
how to take over the body or at least
the mind of the Hulk how to seize
control for himself and then after
learning how to do that that what Banner
had done is he had actually taken over
one of modoc's Texas facilities and then
started imbuing himself with a
technology necessary to be able to
Traverse the space waste right to travel
the Multiverse so that's how all this
seemingly came to where it is right now
now of course when Stephen Strange
realizes what's going on he ends up
sending his astral form into the
Multiverse in order to find uh Bruce
Banner on Hulk Planet and then find a
way to bring the entire conflict to an
end because he kind of sees himself as
being responsible for all of this but
here's the crazy thing about it with
Titan Hulk manifesting and with all
these different world breaker hulks here
on this world they didn't know what they
were getting into right they weren't
necessarily goading the existence of the
Titan Hulk and if anything what they
were actually trying to do was get rid
of the Bruce Banner personality it was
one of the main goals of monolith and
like pave and any of them they saw the
Hulk as the true personality of banner
and the banner personality had to be
eliminated and so by working to get rid
of like all the implants in the Hulk
body getting rid of the technological
advancements and so on and just turning
him into a more pure version of the Hulk
while I wouldn't go as far as to say
they're the reason why manifest it in
the first place I would go so far as to
say they have no idea what they're
dealing with here because as soon as
Titan Hulk shows up monolith sends
Oliver forces after Titan and when she
does they all get wrecked not even in
hell would you see a master like this to
say they get wrecked is just an
understatement right I don't know what
word can adequately be used to
illustrate what's going on here but
these guys never stood a chance in the
first place any attack they launch
against Titan Hulk is met with virtually
no impact whatsoever he doesn't even
really feel anything while Doctor
Strange astral form does show up it does
basically step into the mind of Bruce
Banner and try to fight the personality
of the Titan Hulk while the world
breaker hulks try to fight the physical
form of the Titan Hulk none of it's
helping none of it makes any difference
whatsoever literally the Stephen Strange
Persona is blown out of the mind of
Titan Hulk and then in turn the Titan
Hulk turns his attention to the 500
World breaker Hooks and just starts such
talking all the gamma radiation right
out of them amping himself up even more
and making himself more and more
powerful so much so that what monolith
does is she tells all the other world
breaker hulks that are left to get out
of there while they can right evacuate
leave lest they die and so that's when
Stephen Strange realizes what's actually
going on here what he does is he jumps
back to his Citadel he grabs an orb and
then brings it back to this alternate
universe with his astral form and then
he presents the orc and the person who
emerges from it is despair now despair
is a ridiculously powerful entity in
Marvel Comics and is one of the most
powerful fear Lords to ever exist in the
history of Marvel I mean this guy's
right up there with beings like
nightmare the dweller in darkness so on
and so forth what we end up finding out
here is that for reasons that are never
truly revealed when Bruce Banner met
with Steven strange to learn how to
control the mindscape it was never
Stephen Strange that he actually met
with it was despair masquerading as
Stephen Strange which is a crazy
revelation because again despair only
answers to some of the most powerful
beings in existence which seems to
indicate there are forces out there
within the Multiverse that are of
exceedingly high levels of power that
have a vested interest in seeing the
Titan Hulk personality run a complete
and total Rampage across the Multiverse
which basically seems to happen because
when the attempts by Despair and Stephen
Strange are implemented to contain and
control the Titan Hulk it's too late and
Titan Hulk is seizing control of
everything he's gonna eradicate the
world he's gonna destroy every world in
the vicinity in this immediate solar
system spread to the Galaxy the universe
and even the Multiverse and there's
seemingly nothing anybody can do to stop
it but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
Cliffhangers thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later peace